all right happy labor day guys gail and
anthony are off but dana and michelle
are here with me and we've got a great
show for you we're beginning
our labor day broadcast out in
california where one of the worst heat
waves in california history
is striking the state and it's slowing
efforts to control about two dozen major
wildfires
one of them trapped more than 200 people
surrounded by flames near a popular
campground
in the sierra national forest crews
jammed people on military helicopters to
fly them to safety at least
20 people were taken to hospitals
jonathan vigliotti is in shaver lake
california about 300 miles north of los
angeles
jonathan you spoke with a man who says
he barely escaped
good morning to you the creek fire has
been so erratic
and fast moving that some communities
weren't even under an evacuation at the
time
that incredible rescue happened deep
inside this forest
in an area that is still largely
inaccessible this morning by road in
fact
it took rescue crews more than 12 hours
to get everyone out
safely campers hoping for
a relaxing labor day weekend found
themselves suddenly
trapped by flames the so-called creek
fire
exploded jumping a river and cutting off
the only road out of the mammoth pool
reservoir in the sierra national forest
dennis drake was with his family it was
the
fastest growing fire i had ever even
heard of let alone seen
it was amazing he says he and about 150
people
spent over an hour in the reservoir to
escape the fire
remember it's the size of golf balls
winds going 40 50
60 miles an hour and we just keep going
under and under and under and it's like
in my mind not going okay are we gonna
die from the fire are we gonna die
from drowning drake captured this video
of a military helicopter
landing in the middle of the inferno
what went on your mind when you saw the
first chinook helicopter arrive
whoa i'm going
they are here they made it and
my level of anxiety fear
stress just went from a million to about
10. it was just a big release just a
huge relate historic triple digit
temperatures combined with
dry conditions helped fuel fires across
the state
from san bernardino county to san diego
where at least
11 structures were destroyed and several
more threatened
there's so much fuel at the base of that
hill
i don't know if they'll weather the
storm
and there are reports this morning that
half the town of big creek has been
destroyed by the flames
so far this wildfire season more than 2
million acres have been burned
setting a new record michelle jonathan
thank you stay safe out there